für attac rabbi und seinen sohn ist die
lage hier auf lesbos immer noch ein
überlebenskampf gar keine möglichkeit es
um leben die leute wirklich kämpfen
überleben
die schwierigkeit gibt es gibt es keine
wassers und trinke gibt es keine ist
schon bereit packe ich habe keine wasser
essen bekommen und gibt es keine
sicherheit gibt keine kranken sicherheit
gibt es keine medikamente gibt es keine
alles sieben tage nach dem großbrand im
flüchtlingslager moria leben nach wie
vor tausende flüchtlinge auf der straße
immer wieder kommt es zu spontanen
demonstrationen und protesten
wie verzweifelt die lage vor ort ist
zeigt der appell dieser beiden
migrantenkinder an bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel
ich bin ein kind bitte mama merkel hilft
uns den kindern syriens zwar gibt es
mittlerweile auf lesbos ein neues
provisorisches flüchtlingslager
doch es steht in der kritik für viele
sei es wie ein gefängnis am akbari ist
verzweifelt ich bin von afghanistan nach
gewittern gekommen weil ich habe dort
konnte ich weiterleben
ich habe große probleme deswegen ich bin
nach europa gekommen
momentan ist man ihn eher im lesbos hier
gibt's keine möglichkeit es im leben so
gut deutsch habe der 32-jährige in
österreich gelernt zehn jahre war er als
küchenhelfer in wien bevor er 2016 aus
liebe nach afghanistan zurück gingen
jetzt sucht er nach einer sicheren
bleibe in europa bleiben
wo ist sicherheit für mich die richter
oder frank franke ist egal
aber momentan ist auch dort
ich wollte einen normalen leben in der
u-bahn ins neue lager auf lesbos wolle
akbari nicht stattdessen will er weiter
auf der straße bleiben ein
lebensbedrohlicher umstand vor allem für
seinen kollegen ebrahimi versehrt von
einer kriegs mine bräuchte der 18
jährige eigentlich einen rollstuhl
alleine da dann nicht nur seine leute
realisiert sind schuldigkeit diffus wie
[Musik]
es auf der griechischen insel jetzt
weitergeht ungewiss notfalls helfen
selbst gebaute zelte und kochstellen auf
steine
eins ist aber sicher die migranten auf
lesbos werden auch weiterhin
zusammenhalten
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren